behind closed doors a unanimous vote on
a secret law Beijing imposed its writ on
Hong Kong by passing the city's people
and its Parliament or the Security Law
there was only made public the moment it
came into force and so the Chinese
Communist Party settled in a boardroom
what Hong Kong people had protested in
the streets 1,200 miles away in the
world ago
protesters fought last year often
violently against what they saw as the
tightening grip of the party Hong Kong
is part of China but was promised its
traditional freedoms one country two
systems' Hong Kong's leader Carrie Lam
who admitted last week that she had not
even seen the full text of the national
security legislation said there was
nothing to fear he's short the
legislation will not undermine one
country two systems and Hong Kong high
degree of autonomy Hong Kong is a free
and diversified society we respect
differences in opinion and strive on
reaching consensus but the wine-country
principle is non-negotiable and could
not be compromised as without one
country two systems will stand on shaky
ground and Hong Kong's stability and
prosperity will be at risk but the text
of the law published shortly before
midnight met its critics fears
subversion secession terrorism and
colluding with foreign forces all carry
a maximum life sentence but they're
drawn incredibly widely terrorism
includes vandalism of public transport
subversion includes obstructing the
authority of the government much is
vague left for Beijing which has awarded
itself the ultimate power of oversight
in national security cases to interpret
as it sees fit of course it's aimed at
terrifying and terrorizing the local
population turning Hong Kong into a dead
city without dissent without any
opposition voice it has already had that
effect leading pro-democracy activists
have resigned political organizations
have
tomorrow is the 23rd anniversary of the
handover of Hong Kong from the UK to
China traditionally it is a day of mass
protest Beijing created this law
swiftly and secretly to raise the stakes
for dissent tomorrow on the streets of
Hong Kong it will meet its first test
Tom Cheshire Sky News Beijing